every black hole of the same mass and
they also have a spin is according to
Einstein according to their equations
exactly the same and this puzzled people
and the great John Wheeler who also
invented the word black hole described
this by saying a black hole has no hair
that is it's a featureless object so if
you have two bald people in the room you
can't distinguish them by their hairdos
if you do people with their you could
say what as a short haircut the other
one has a comb-over whatever there's
many different distinguishing features
so stars are like people with hundred
black holes or like bold people they're
all the same and well if you can't see
very well so he envisioned if you say
threw a cup of tea I think is the the
metaphor that he is you take a cup of
tea and you sort of throw it into a
black hole he was worried that the the
information carried by the tea the
entropy of people the disorder care
about the tea would have no way of
showing up inside a black hole because
like you say it has no hair and they all
look the same right today this Tim was a
puzzle that you could sort of get rid of
entropy by throwing it inside a black
hole and it would be gone from the
universe and his student bekenstein
began to think about this and he gave
insights that ultimately led to your
work what was his view of this puzzle
well they were very bothered so going
back to Newton and before there is an
idea which is very important to
physicists namely that there are laws of
physics and moreover we like to think
that the laws of physics govern
everything that happens if we knew all
of them and if we had perfect knowledge
and part of that is that information
should never be lost things can't just
disappear and so if you throw a cup
Coffee or a computer or your diary or
something into a black hole according to
the way that Einstein would have
described them there's no trace of it
left
it's just vanished and that is
antithetical to everything that
physicists would like to believe
[Music]